When you're at the controls of a giant franchise,
you can't please everybody and this seems
to go double for Star Wars fans.
Disney CEO Bob Iger took a philosophical approach
to fans' dissatisfaction with the sequel trilogy
during a conversation with Variety at the
Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker premiere.
Iger acknowledged that, while the creative
minds behind the series tried to be mindful
of what fans wanted, they were also aware
of the fine line between fan service and simple
pandering.
"We don't overreact to that, we respect fans
of Star Wars, that's really important to us,
to Lucasfilm, to the franchise.
But we do the best job we possibly can."
Iger expressed his own satisfaction with the
job that his filmmakers had done on the sequels,
including J.J. Abrams, who as the co-writer
and director of The Rise of Skywalker had
the unenviable task of bringing the nine-film
Skywalker Saga to a close in a way that would
be true to all of the movies that came before,
while still giving fans everything they wanted
and telling his own unique story.
“We've done a really good job of threading
that needle, walking that fine line.
We respect our fans, but we don't overreact
to it either."
Brace yourself for a shock: many fans and
critics disagree.
One of the common complaints about Rise of
Skywalker has concerned its willingness to
indulge in fan service at the expense of its
story, which can be seen as course-correction
away from the daring narrative choices made
in the series' previous installment, The Last
Jedi.
While that film was one of the best-reviewed
in the entire series, it supremely divided
fans some of whom now feel that Abrams has
swung too far back in the opposite direction.
Another pervasive gripe: that Rise of Skywalker
was illustrative of the fact that the trilogy
as a whole lacked a unified vision, which
may be why there has recently been talk of
future Star Wars movies straying away from
the trilogy format.
Lucasfilm President Kathleen Kennedy suggested
as much during an interview with the Los Angeles
Times the weekend before the release of Episode
IX.
She said,
"I think [focusing on single films] gives
us a more open-ended view of storytelling
and doesn't lock us into this three-act structure.
We're not going to have some finite number
and fit it into a box.
We're really going to let the story dictate
that."
Iger, however, implied that her comments should
be taken with a grain of salt.
"Oh, I don't know about that.
She and I have said, 'Well, maybe trilogies
are too hard, so maybe we'll make one film
and then a sequel,' but we don't know."
Of course, it's likely that some observers
will take this as yet further evidence that
the stewards of Star Wars lack a clear vision
for the property but even the staunchest critics
would have to agree that the House of Mouse
hasn't done everything wrong.
"So, I'm, still in command…?"
In fact, one thing has gone very, very right
for Disney's Star Wars endeavors of late:
The Mandalorian, the Disney+ series that has
drawn critical raves, helped amass millions
of subscribers for the nascent streaming service,
and launched a bonafide pop culture icon in
"the Child," the adorable character better
known to fans and the world at large as Baby
Yoda.
Iger admitted that, while he obviously had
high hopes for the series' success, even he
was blindsided by its rapturous reception.
"I think it would be wrong for me to say I
knew exactly how everybody would react because
it's been huge, but I did have a strong sense
it was a character people were going to love."
Perhaps The Mandalorian could help provide
some guidance for Disney and Lucasfilm brass
on how to effectively engage fans going forward
that is, beyond "put Baby Yoda in everything,"
which we honestly wouldn't have much of a
problem with.
Season 2 of the series is currently in production,
and if creator/showrunner Jon Favreau is able
keep fans hooked, Iger and Kennedy would do
well to take a good hard look at how they
could apply some of his Mando magic to future
Star Wars films.
"I gotta get one of those."
Of course, they've also reached out for a
little help from across the hall; in a development
which the Star Wars faithful have simply got
to be pumped about, it was announced in September
that Marvel boss Kevin Feige who has had just
a little bit of success in developing beloved
properties for the big screen to the utter
delight of fans has been tapped to help develop
a new Star Wars picture.
"This will begin to set things right."
While we won't see the fruits of this arrangement
for quite some time, that's okay Iger has
made it clear that Disney won't be rushing
any new Star Wars flicks to market after The
Rise of Skywalker, but will instead place
the property on a 2 or 3 year hiatus while
the direction of the franchise is worked out.
"We'll see about that."
All of which is to say that while the sequel
trilogy may not have been exactly what everybody
hoped for, the future of Star Wars still looks
reasonably bright.
Also, it must be said: the Mouse House may
not have fielded a perfect trio of films,
but hey, they were better than the prequels,
right?
"I'm not sure I understand."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.